the fastest way to get to where you want
to be how can I be so productive I want
to make as much money as I can to help
as many people as I can to have as much
fun as I can I live in the real world
and it takes money to help people it
takes money to have fun if you learn to
love what you do not only will you not
work a day in your life but even more
importantly it will tell you all its
Secrets these are the two biggest
problems of entrepreneurs and guess what
solves it
David Meltzer I am so fired up to get
into five daily practices for boosting
your productivity making more money as a
business owner entrepreneur content
creator but for those that are just
meeting you you're the co-founder of
Sports One marketing and you formally
served as CEO for the renowned lay
Steinberg sports and entertainment
agency which was the inspiration for
Jerry Maguire you've wrote a bunch of
books you've done a bunch of really cool
things you wrote a book a game time
decision making which was the number one
release and as a content creator
yourself almost 50 000 subscribers on
YouTube almost 500 000 on Instagram and
so you really can bring kind of
Entrepreneurship and business into this
content creation World Super fired up to
uh have you on the podcast today how's
it going amazing thanks for having me
and any opportunity I have to explain
how the Middle East mutant turtle
actually built a brand when I spent most
of my life building other people's
Brands product services and solutions
but have applied it now to my own person
yeah I love it and so let's dive into
this you created did five daily
practices and uh let's kick it off with
number one it's kind of a framework that
we're going to be able to use and the
first one on here is uh no year what
break this down or maybe give us the big
high level vision of how this can help
us get more done yeah well first of all
notice their daily practices I have a
philosophy about two minutes a day is
worth more than two hours on a Saturday
I think a lot of people live in the
extra mile the extra mile is overrated
people live in the extra mile and
they're like oh you know I stayed up
until two in the morning on Saturday
doing this project and what they do is
they use that extra mile when they went
the extra mile every once in a while to
justify why they're not where they want
to be instead of going to what I call
the empty mile by using five daily
practices to enjoy the consistent
everyday daily practices persistent
without quit pursuit of their own
potential so the idea of the daily
practices is not only I'm gonna do every
everything today I'm going to do say
think believe and feel everything today
in a trajectory of what I think I want
notice the radical humility that I don't
really know what I want but I'm going to
aim to something really big but in that
trajectory I'm going to do everything I
can because most people have a problem
reconciling two things persistence and
patience
they'll tell me all the time what do you
mean detached from the outcome how can
you have any goals you no no trust me I
got goals every day
but my daily practices are like a pit
bull in a china shop I mean I hold on to
a tire you can't get away from me but
I'm patient about the outcomes in the
future because it's just a trajectory
and there's one Nuance before we get
into the five daily practices especially
of knowing our what is that a lot of
people don't consider the past you see
one of the aspects that I do about my
daily practices is I make sure the
meaning of my past the defining moments
the inflection points the mistakes the
setbacks and failures that occurs in
everyone's life and believe me I lost
over 100 million dollars went bankrupt
right I had everything when I ran Lee
Steinberg Sports entertainment the most
notable sports agency in the world Not
only was I a multi-millionaire but I had
access to what billionaires couldn't
even afford and I gave the meaning to my
bankruptcy 15 years ago one of
protection and promotion not punishment
which allows me to utilize the daily
practices and the trajectory of what I
think I want without interfering or
limiting Myself by my past so many
people beat themselves up I had one lady
one time I was in France speaking and
she said well you know about the
french-american war don't you and I'm
like you're gonna let the
french-american war get in the way of
your future you're killing me so the
first step of knowing your what makes
the nothingness that most people live in
they live as tubes not YouTubes but
tubes food in food out right rolling a
boulder to the top of the hill just have
it at the bottom the next day because
why they live in a world of nothingness
and you can change the mathematical
equation by knowing your what because
the minute you know what you want
personally experientially giving and
receiving wise today in the trajectory
of what you think you want in the future
your nothingness your tube becomes a
possibility a mathematical Advantage so
the first step is to take a few moments
every day and say what is it I want
today personally a health family Finance
experientially jumping out of a plane
going to you know your studio filming a
TV show whatever experiences you want
giving wise which is so important to me
how can I be so productive right to be
able to give as much value as I can to
everyone which is what you do I just had
one of my young Associates working here
compliment you for how much you've
changed or impact their life that's
giving every day it's on your what and
then of course the one that everyone
doesn't utilize well enough which is
receiving so many people good good
people and I was one of them we felt
guilty receiving and I changed the
Paradigm no more giving to receive I
receive so I can give more the more
money I have the more good I can do and
it's a complete paradigm shift so
knowing your what takes nothingness and
making it a possibility and you do it
every day so whatever amount of time you
spend it's aggregating accelerating and
compounding by doing it every day living
in the empty mile so are you waking up
and doing this first thing and
journaling this correct so what I do is
very quick I I meditate every morning I
always say my tomorrow starts today so I
have an unwinding routine that puts my
body mind and soul in a position of
access and recovery so I wake up and I
meditate first to get clarity to gather
the information from my sleep when my
conscience isn't interfering with ego
and I just gather this data and then
what I do is I just quickly chart out
those four buckets personal experiential
giving receiving but I always have an
arrow so if I have you know personal
goal for example I do a minimum of an
hour a day
uh on my health and I have an arrow that
shows the number 111 plus why because in
the trajectory of what I think I want
today now I'm not sure of it because
there could be some nuclear Holocaust
and I could change my mind about my
trajectory but today when I woke up my
mission is to live to over 111 years old
I was born on January 11th at 111. so I
make my mission my trajectory of living
over so today I'm going to make sure I
give a minimum of an hour on my health
because aggregated accelerated that's
going to give me the most statistical
success of getting that mission so I
have those things each day and it's
reconciling with the later steps as well
as as we'll get to awesome and so so you
open start out the day you're listening
to this you pull out a piece of paper a
journal you're defined in personal do
what are your plans for the future what
it what do you want for your character
your love your integrity what do you
want to learn today what can you do to
maximize and experience get the most
instead of these 24 hours what do you
want to give to others today what do you
want to receive today and you're
answering these questions you're writing
down a few thoughts do you use a
physical Journal are you digital so I do
both because remember I have even in
branding a stage Theory which we'll
probably get to later on in the
interview but I believe what you do in
the physical then becomes digital so if
I put a billboard up on the street I'm
making sure that I capture the physical
modif so it's modifiable amplifiable and
perpetuated and so it's very important I
think for everyone to start with
physical because why not get two bangs
for the buck yeah I like it okay so then
you're you're doing this daily practice
know your what number two is know your
who what is this one all about so in
order to take our possibilities of what
we want and make it a probability
another mathematical Advantage for the
day which Aggregates accelerates and
compounds for the future I ask myself
okay here's what I want today in that
trajectory who can I help with it
because I know how much value and how
things work in the universe that if I
utilize my intention to help others that
I will receive a value-add in my life
not a zero sum but secondly the most
overlooked is not who I can help because
I am truly under the perspective that
99.9 of the people on Earth want to do
good and want to help each other they
want to give once again the other part
of who is who can help me so many people
don't realize that radical humility lies
in your ability to to find people who
sit in a situation that you want to be
in and ask for help it's the fastest way
to get to where you want to be is to
find someone that's already there and
ask him for directions right when I came
to the studio I didn't just guess how to
get here right I found the greatest
source and asked it for directions on
how to get here and so many people miss
out on this so if you know what you want
and then who can help you and who you
could help it takes your possibility and
gives it another mathematical leap of a
probability so what would you say to
someone that then identifies someone
they want to learn from or collaborate
with or connect with but is afraid to
reach out or just assumes that their
these people are too busy like they
can't get their attention why would that
person say yes to me you have tips for
connecting with people that can you know
get you where you want to go it's a
habit so any habit is formed by practice
lower the bar tell yourself today I'm
going to ask one person in person one
person on the phone one person via email
and one person via social media just one
person a day you're going to start
practicing and instead of creating
interference void shortages and
obstacles instead of looking for what
you don't want instead of creating more
resistance all of a sudden by lowering
the bar not only will you get in the
habit of asking for help but you'll get
reassurance and confirmation that
everybody wants to help you that instead
of living in the zero-sum game that if I
ask for help that person's losing and
I'm winning instead put it into the
paradigm shift that when someone asks me
for help when I'm able to help someone I
feel at my best my higher self I never
feel better than when people ask me for
help and I can help them why not give
that opportunity to someone else also
mathematically think about this if you
have four ass a day which doesn't take
very much time yeah especially because
of technology today if you have four
hours today that's 28 ass a week that's
112 asks on average a month imagine if
10 percent of the people say yes and
ninety percent say no most people will
be discouraged by those numbers not me
because at 112 people a month on average
you have 11 people that are helping you
a month yeah do you know what
exponential results you will get by
finding people who sit in the situation
you want and 11 people are giving you
directions most people have zero imagine
why I got to where I got to twice in my
life because not only am I giving and
being of value and service to people but
more importantly I am a student of
habits of asking for help people ask me
what would you do and tell your 18 year
old self ask for help
that's literally the best piece of
advice I can give you that's so powerful
and I mean it's a big one for Content
creators you're in media as well you've
interviewed celebrities
um you've connected with really high
level people and I know a lot listening
to this might again what do you think
about that imposter syndrome or maybe
the fact too that I mean if you don't
have a platform yet how do you reach out
to someone that's further than you do
you got to build up that Authority first
you know what is your thoughts for
really actually maybe accessing Next
Level podcasts guests that seems just
absolutely impossible yeah so I know
that part of the advantage that I had
and I've done 1400 uh podcasts right in
playbooks and I have TV shows and all
the because I ran the most notable
sports agency I had those relationships
but I also have people who ask me not
only for help hey will you come on my
show but they asked me can you introduce
me
to the people that I know and sometimes
they're not ready yet and I explained to
them hey if I got you at my let who's a
close friend of mine or you know Tom
bill you or some of the guys is not
going to do you any good right now
because you don't have a million
subscribers and you know but there is
opportunity within the context of people
wanting to help people and so as you
build up and get better I when I coach
people on content I always tell them I
need 10 episodes in the can before we
post anything for two reasons one it
puts you in the top one percent because
most people quit before they get to 10
episodes of anything and on the other it
allows you to practice because what
happens is being kind to your future
self one of the superpowers is not just
that I knew all these people it's that
when I went on Tom billu's impact Theory
or met at my let guys that aren't Sports
athletes that I was well versed in
practice like you you're an exceptional
interviewer so what am I going to do I'm
gonna go tell all my famous friends you
know whether you want them or not hey
this guy is amazing he's PR I came in on
time prepared unbelievable questions
super intelligence and he has a
following that's the last thing I'll say
because I have people that want me to
interview them now just because I'm a
great interviewer and people want to
interview me because I bring quality
productive value when I'm being
interviewed and that's the biggest key
to have them focus in on that the
audience grows think about this when I
met garyvee I didn't even know what a
garyvee was I knew his brother because I
was helping with the sports agency that
he wanted to create it was Super Bowl
time aj his brother said hey so someone
said oh garyvee's here and AJ picked up
like what's a garyvee and AJ laughing
because that's my brother I'm like oh
what does he do and he's like Dave you
don't know my brother I'm like no I'm
sorry he's all he's an Instagram King
he's that I said wow he I said let me
help him with the sports agency he's oh
yeah sit down with him Gary tells me you
got to change I had a radio show across
the country said you got to make it a
podcast I'm like there's 200 000
podcasts Gary why would I do that and he
convinced me why and he said to me Dave
what's your objective I said same as it
was with the radio show two people
he said what are you talking about I
said I will invest money in the podcast
if I can get two people by the end of
the year that will tell two people you
have to listen to David Meltzer that
will get two more people a year why
because I was 50 years old and I told
Gary if I can get two people a year I
know that doesn't sound like a lot so it
shouldn't be intimidating for anyone
starting today but if you can get two
people a year if you can rehearse enough
practice enough two people a year that
will get you two people a year and those
two people as well by the time I'm 70
I'll have two million people getting Me
2 million people a year and that will
change lives man what an insight and
unlock thing about The Compound Effect
and patience
um and so many nuggets in there so
number one was know your what number two
is know your who so then thirdly as
we're doing these daily practices we're
boosting our productivity we're getting
Fierce Clarity know your how break this
down well I have a tool to know your how
and it's called be a student of the
calendar I don't say look at your
calendar I don't say glance at your
calendar I don't say fill out your
calendar I say be a student of your
account because students they manifest
or manufacture the mathematical equation
to luck what do I mean by that what does
a student do in the how a student
studies they pay attention to with
lenses of productivity you mentioned
that you picked up on that but also
lenses of accessibility how accessible
am I to others and how am I accessing
what I want and a lens which I'm known
for with my brand my Essence my
authenticity and all those au words by
the way in the English language the Au
the root the Latin root means Feeling by
the way just let that sink in so
productivity accessibility and of course
gratitude I'm constantly looking how can
I find the light the love and the
lessons in my activities today in a
trajectory towards the future see if you
know your how it takes the possibility
of the probability now it creates
something that's so powerful your
perspective and most people don't
realize it but your life is about your
participation and your perspective it's
about the activities that you have to be
efficient effective and statistically
successful and to use the mathematical
equation of being a student what you pay
attention to and what you give intention
to by your calendar this is what I'm
going to do today say today think today
believe today and feel today in the
trajectory of where I want to be to be
over 111 years old or double the amount
of money I can make as fast as I can or
help over a billion people whatever your
trajectory is that can change tomorrow
you then have the mathematical equation
that I'm looking for what you pay
attention to and what you give intention
to equals the coincidences in your life
so powerful and you're defining know
your how you have a tool called the
Eisenhower Matrix
so this is defining your tax tasks in a
day so this is how you're going to get
to your what and you're going to Define
tasks as important and Urgent or
important and not urgent or urgent and
not important or not urgent and not
important so kind of four buckets and so
you could prioritize what's going to be
the biggest needle mover absolutely so
importance is self-defined what's
important to me is not important to you
and that's okay in fact most people get
into the problem is they try to make
what's important what's important to
other people and then they end up with
other people want and then not only do
they end up unhappy but resentful of the
people that care the most about them or
they end up thinking what's important to
other people is what they don't want and
they end up with what they don't want so
importance and urgency are are related
but urgency is a subset it's not the
priority in your activities see there's
different types of activities activities
you have planned and activities you
don't have planned and your sleep
there's activity you get paid for an
activity you don't get paid for see I
value money I want to make as much money
as I can to help as many people as I can
to have as much fun as I can I live in
the real world and it takes money to
help people and it takes money to have
fun in fact so I want to have as much as
I can and so so that's a priority that's
important to me and I don't allow
urgency to get in the way of the
activity I get paid for I'm constantly
looking how I can have activity I love
this and I get paid for this yeah I love
this you love this you get paid for this
yeah we figure it out a way in order to
monetize helping people yes what a great
thing and then we use that money to help
more people yes it's awesome so I want
people to think about what's important
to me and decipher
urgency as a subset so I'm going to do
what's urgent and important first then
what's important then what's urgent then
what's not important and not urgent yeah
and in order to do that that leads me to
that fourth step
yeah and the fourth step is uh know your
now
break it down yeah I've actually
enhanced that a little bit uh recently I
say no you're now and know you're next
think about this if you know what to do
now because you know what's important in
Urgent Etc from the what The Who and the
how then your perception becomes your
reality when you do it now a hundred
percent of the things you do now get
done but even more importantly if you
know what's important to you you'll know
what to do now and know what to do next
so when God laughs at you with your
well-developed plan of how you'll know
exactly what to do now and you'll know
what to do next if you know what to do
now and next it's the antidote to the
two biggest problems of entrepreneurs
procrastination and overwhelmed these
are the two biggest problems of
entrepreneurs and guess what solves it
knowing you're now it is impossible to
procrastinate if you know what to do now
and know what to do next and it's
impossible to feel overwhelmed if you
know what to do now and know what to do
next so I use that as the antidote to
take the possibility to probability
probability perspective and make my
perspective My Reality by the
materialization of the actual execution
of knowing what to do now because 100 of
the things I do now get done and if I
know what to do next my now becomes next
and vice versa it's an amazing
productivity accessibility and gratitude
tool so
is this framework also stacking because
I think at the end of the day uh content
creators entrepreneurs they know that
until you make a video until you
actually land that collab and actually
film the thing until you actually edit
it and post it until you actually do the
real work but sometimes exactly what you
said you're either overwhelmed so you're
paralyzed you don't know what to do next
you're just overwhelmed with all the
options so you do nothing or you
procrastinate I mean is the framework
stacking so that we're in a more
empowered state by the time we reach our
now or what is your advice for those
that actually just feel like they get in
to a slog of not necessarily just eating
the Frog doing the hard work wasting
time yeah so it it is a matter of
alignment and adjustment and then taking
action and preparing for adjustments so
I have a triple a strategy I'm going to
get alignment through the daily
practices right I know my what we get
alignment then we we take action right
after we have the alignment of the what
and the who we take action in the how
and the now and then I'm preparing for
adjustment see one of the things about
that overwhelmed feeling that you're
talking about is a mindset between once
again scarcity of a zero-sum game an
abundance of a value-add world and so
those people that feel overwhelmed
should say to themselves I'm so blessed
I have more than enough I have more than
enough options opportunities and touches
a favor but I know one thing I can only
do one thing at a time
right I can only focus in on one thing
at a time this this is like biochemical
truth you can only focus in on one thing
at a time therefore if I know my now and
I know my next I'm going to be most
efficient effective and statistically
successful and I'll be able to detach my
emotions from the outcome
which leads us to the step number five
of The Daily practices
[Music]
this video was brought to you by stream
yard stream yard is our go-to platform
for streaming to YouTube and Facebook
with an incredibly easy to use interface
for built-in branding transitions text
lower thirds and seamlessly bringing on
guests it really is one of the best
options when it comes to live streaming
and what's so cool is they've
implemented a brand new feature called
local recording take control of your
audio and video with local recordings by
separating out your audio and video from
your guests this feature gives you the
control over your content for later use
making it perfect for podcasts and video
creators just go to streamwoodthink.com
to get started now
so I think you're listening to this you
can already imagine starting your day
not just scrolling on your phone you got
some memes some bad news hitting you not
just doing nothing let your mind wander
but putting a real Focus intentional
practice five daily practices stacking
these journaling these and even as
you're listening to this it's a good
time to start but number five is
ultimately apply your why break this
down this is the major shift in my life
I spent all of that time early on in my
career worth over a hundred million
dollars before I went bankrupt searching
for more I wanted to be more happy more
healthy more wealthy more worthy and I
never had enough because there's always
more once I realized how to apply my why
instead of search for my why how many
entrepreneurs for example tell you I'm
looking for my passion I'm looking for
my why and I tell them all the time it's
already there now in a non-religious
philosophical theoretical or spiritual
sense I have a core base philosophy in
my head that there's something bigger
than me and omniscient all-powerful
all-knowing source that loves me more
than my mom
so just as when I was three years old
and went to reach a stove and my mom
slapped my hand and screamed no at me
and I started to cry saying why are you
punishing me what did I do and she
hugged me and said I love you I'm
protecting you you just don't know
that's going to burn you that's the
basis of applying my why is that my mom
doesn't know what she doesn't know now
she knows the stove is going to burn me
but she didn't know the internet wasn't
going to be a fad so when I got out of
law school and she told me be a real
lawyer don't go in the internet she was
trying to protect me when she told me to
be a real lawyer that was bad advice by
the way yeah just because someone loves
you doesn't mean they give you good
advice but for me
I look at my life and say I'm applying
my why so what do I do I go ahead and
say I'm being protected and potent so if
I don't get the job I don't get
followers my video bombs I'm just being
protected and promoted not punished and
so what I do is spend my life in a
reverse Paradigm Shift of I am I am
happy I am healthy I am wealthy I am
worthy what am I doing to interfere with
it and that fear is f-e-a-r not f e r
interfere with it so the practice of
applying your why is to identify the two
fears in everyone's life fear of the
past and fear of the future fear of the
past manifests itself in regret and
guilt mostly and fear of the future
results in worrying anxiety and they
have subcategories which I later on
identify and practice but if you go
ahead and practice instead of trying to
get more identifying what you're doing
to interfere with it by saying oh I feel
guilty and instead of trying to out
logic get resisted oversell it back and
sell it live in later cheated simply
stop breathe remind remember and
recollect what do I want who can I help
who can help me how to get it done and
reprioritize my now and next now I'm
applying my why instead of in search for
something I already have so in other
words when you identify the two fears of
the past or the future
know that your mind your body and soul
are on fire
when you're on fire stop drop and roll
back into the trajectory of what you
think you want and so it is is it your
belief that why is the driving force
um it's that the why that's going to
empower clarifying what is it you're
doing how are you going to get there
um what do you need to do most what are
your priorities but then why are you
doing it all is that the idea here think
of the definition of inspiration
in spirit if you're inspired those
people know their why what is that in
spirit yeah I know that I'm part and
parcel denomination all powerful knowing
source that loves me more than my mom
therefore if I clear the interference
between me and that then I'm going to be
inspired or be with my my wire apply my
why most people I'm 55 years old they
can't keep up with me they're like how
do you have so much energy it's four in
the morning you know my kids drive them
crazy yeah well I'm like you understand
that we both have the same amount of
energy I just have figured out how to
not interfere with what I've already
been given my inspiration wow and what
would you say to somebody who
when they you have a ton of clarity
you've galve you've clarified with
language
um your beliefs your driving force they
might look at something like think media
we've developed our vision developed our
mission but sometimes you're sitting in
a place where someone's like have an
inspirational why but you may just kind
of feel like a Blake slate do you
recommend a practice for someone to
uncover like sometimes we'll encourage
people you should have a bigger Mission
around your YouTube channel and they're
like it's just kind of a hobby what do
you mean bigger Mission like how do you
dig deeper to find greater dimensions of
why this is a beautiful question and a
guy named Bob Parsons uh changed my
perspective recently about it Bob
Parsons the founder of GoDaddy exited
for over four billion dollars and I talk
about learning to love what you do right
don't just think that you you're gonna
find something you love to do right I
learned to love what I do by finding the
light the love and the lessons by
enjoying the consistent persistent
pursuit of whatever potential it is for
me I play division three football all
and I you know joke around and I say
that I was an average division three
football player I was probably below
average but there was no activity that I
ever enjoyed the consistent persistent
pursuit of my potential of right I I
just I love it changed my whole life and
I learned more from it and this is what
Bob Parsons said and I want everyone to
think about it because if you know your
what you're who and your how and you
know you're now you can apply this why
regardless of its you know having a
million subscribers on YouTube
if you learn to love what you do
not only will you not work a day in your
life but even more importantly if you
learn to love what you do it will tell
you all its secrets
and those Secrets make the difference
you know so many more secrets than I
know about YouTube why because I started
by focusing in on Instagram and LinkedIn
because I felt as if that was an
audience that I best could align with in
my mission to empower over a billion
people to be happy and then slowly but
surely I'm one of the few people I met
with Evan Carmichael pretty big YouTube
guy right and he's like Dave you have 50
000 subscribers on YouTube I'm like
really
I've never even done anything but post
like almost unedited videos yeah he goes
that is remarkable so now I have shifted
my Paradigm in focus and part of the
reason I'm here right I want to learn
from you because I think if I pay
attention and give intention to my
YouTube that I can grow to have a
million subscribers and Empower more
people aligned with my mission and so
it's so important for people to I'm
going to Learn to Love YouTube yes
that's what I'm gonna do now and it's
gonna tell me the secrets that you know
that give you the exponentiality of
success within YouTube the way that I
have it on Tick Tock or Instagram or
LinkedIn so it's so powerful you broke
down these five practices this is going
to give us Fierce Clarity and once we
have that we can attack our day every
day daily practices
um and especially for the the goal of
podcast listeners here so that we can
make a greater impact with our content
so let's kind of switch gears and and
talk a little bit about content
um I know you've got some powerful
things on how to create Unstoppable
confidence
as and it could be intimidating to get
on camera if we haven't yet or maybe
even tapped into our voice so we'll get
into some tips and your tips for Content
Creation in general but we're going to
kind of hit a lightning round right in
the middle here I'm curious why is it
that you create content
to empower others to empower others that
it's really simple I capture everything
my Essence to empower people to empower
other people to be happy I have paid a
load of dummy tax and I want people not
to have to pay the most expensive tax
there is forget California taxes it is
dummy tax yeah right I lost over 100
million dollars I had the wrong vision
of what it was to be happy yeah I can
teach people to teach people how to make
a lot of money in abundance help a lot
of people in abundance and have a lot of
fun in abundance and I've never met one
person who makes a lot of money in
abundance helps a lot of people in
abundance and has a lot of fun in
abundance every day that isn't super
happy yeah
um very specific question YouTube TV's
CEO confirms that they're getting the
NFL Sunday Ticket what do you think
about this genius I I've been in this
this is my core competency right Sports
executive yeah technology media and I
feel sorry for DirecTV when August comes
there's going to be a huge problem for
DirecTV because all TV has been based
off of bug lights right and you have one
Super Bowl and then all your other
programming you advertise around the
Super Bowl DirecTV's bug Light is Sunday
Ticket yeah and YouTube stole it and
they got a bargain trust me it's the
number one sport in America two to one
for everyone women men children and they
just got the biggest bug Light to
YouTube and it's going to generate so
many eyeballs to see all the other
extraordinary value of YouTube which is
by the way part of the reason why I now
am going to Learn to Love YouTube the
way that I did Instagram link and and
Tick Tock yeah so what do you think
about the state and the kind of platform
War obviously meta Instagram and
Facebook Tick Tock YouTube Pinterest
LinkedIn obviously they all want
eyeballs they all want users what is
your personal prediction as it pertains
to YouTube's dominance or those that are
a threat to YouTube YouTube's dominance
will in its form
be the leader now remember tick tock's a
completely different animal I don't
think they compete with YouTube I don't
think people go to YouTube for the same
reason they go to tick tock and what I
do know is YouTube is going to take an
exponential leap in the form of
Education information Direction and
entertainment and I think it's more
competing with Netflix Amazon Prime and
some other content providers for long
form content yeah you're going to see
huge viewership and billions of people
on YouTube that were never there before
and people like you and I are going to
benefit exponentially wow
um what is your thought of short form
versus long-form video you create both
so vertical is everywhere Instagram
reels Tick Tock YouTube shorts you do a
lot of long form you do these interviews
you've interviewed thousands thousands
of people so so when you're coaching
others on content creation do you
recommend a mix what's your thinking
about short form versus long form
everything I I believe in the content
game that you need to know number one
your essence so you need to know and how
I Define essence to people is your
skills your knowledge of who and what
that's why I have so many interviews of
other people and you do too and then
also uh your skills your knowledge and
your desire your frequency is your
desire and people they fall into
categories right ten percent of people
are going to love you no matter what 10
are going to hate you no matter what and
then through consistent persistent
posting and form you're going to capture
more and more of the 80 in the middle
that just needs some education and some
alignment people grow on people they get
familiar and comfortable with it but
you'll never get the 10 that hate you so
you just gotta let that be and let them
attack you it's fine you know someone
said I stole gratitude from garyvee I
was like how's that possible I'm older
than he is and my mom taught me when I
was three gratitude so I had it first
yeah he didn't steal from me I didn't
steal from him anyway uh when we're
looking at that though if you know your
essence now you capture your essence in
its natural form and most of its longer
form then from that you can modify it to
the different alignment with you know
Instagram reels Facebook fan pages Tick
Tock LinkedIn a lot of people don't
understand LinkedIn has a different
format right I can transcribe what I do
into a Blog that is well suited for
LinkedIn from a long form video that I'm
just posting on YouTube and so I believe
that you start with your essence you
capture the essence you modify it to fit
the platforms then you amplify it
through this type of interaction and
collaborations and other things that we
do and the one thing that YouTube has
better than anyone
perpetuation so when I did my TED Talk
and I wasn't at all involved in YouTube
I was the top TED Talk sub got the most
new viewers from my TED Talk speech and
it was like 550 because I didn't have a
YouTube right but it was the most well
that thing gets like millions of views
today why because it's perpetual because
when someone goes down to David Meltzer
Rabbit Hole like they go down your
rabbit hole all that stuff is
perpetuated and they keep going like the
young lady that I told you that watched
Bob Proctor every day Bob Proctor is
dead yeah his stuff is there forever
yeah that's powerful we we use the term
Evergreen I grew up in Seattle evergreen
trees yeah and building up a body of
work building up that body of influence
one more kind of lightning question
there's a lot of people thinking that
and making videos and kind of maybe
perpetuating fear maybe the fear is
Justified that AI is going to change
everything uh what is your thinking
about AI are you embracing using it are
you on the chat GPT train what is
happening in your companies in your
business so I've been in technology
since 1992. when my mom told me the
internet was a fad yeah and nine months
later I bought our house in a car yeah
right so web one's still here and people
told me the same thing about web one Web
Two web 2.5 and web 3. uh I will tell
you this about technology the biggest
lesson that I can teach people and why I
embrace AI why Embrace AI why I use all
aspects of technology is it's my servant
too many people think it's this master
it's this leader chat GPT can't lead you
it's a great servant it's an enhanced
encyclopedia it's an incredible starting
point and you know for me I could spend
years to create a script about my life
right or I could start at you know uh
Baseline 10 instead of Baseline one and
save 10 years and just say hey chat GPT
write a script about Dave meltzer's life
from the time he was five years old
until he lost over 100 million dollars
and then I'd have all this great data
about my own life that I can't even
remember right yeah in format yeah in
format yeah so it's a great servant you
know Genie get me this but Genie's not
leading you you can't wish for more
wishes right so I want people to embrace
technology as a servant and you'll be
the leader uh so powerful now one of the
things when it comes to creating content
is people say Okay YouTube is Perpetual
vertical videos spreading across the
internet I can make an impact to more
people I think if you're listening to
this you're convinced in the power of it
the potential of it but we still
hesitate maybe because of imposter
syndrome and sometimes it's just flat
out scary to get on camera and punch
fear in the face and press record
what is your advice for building your
confidence and for those that just
hesitate to get on camera and actually
start creating content don't post
create
don't poke crate start practicing and
get a good feeling it's the same thing
as selling right I tell people all the
time you know the difference between the
guy that gets the higher price first the
exact same item than someone else it's
his comfort level of articulating a
quantitative value to exceed what he's
asking for perceived value is all in
your comfort level of explaining that
value and so if you have imposter
syndrome if you're afraid of getting on
and nobody's there
then practice every day creating content
the iPhone you know when I started and
you started content the iPhone does more
than the whole crew that we used to set
up with you know 4K cameras or RED
cameras there's a red phone right now
that I used right I'm like holy family
wow a red phone yeah but more
importantly go ahead that's why people
do 10 episodes start practicing because
when you feel comfortable about your
content by practicing look when I
started playing golf I did not want to
be in a tournament in front of you know
those programs that they're inviting me
to thousands of people watching me play
golf because I sucked why did I suck
because I hadn't done it before so I
think the best thing you can do if
you're afraid of and people are afraid
of two things being laughed at scoffed
out and made fun of or nobody's showing
up
both are healed by you practicing
because if you get to learn to love how
to do content what other format or
whatever you like however you do it then
when you go and post it and no one's
there eventually two people will be
there because ten percent of the people
are going to love you no matter what Dr
pimple popper has more subscribers than
you and who would have thought that
pimple popping or how about the little
kid that opens toys yeah do you think
that's like super valuable no but they
follow And subscribe to the consistent
persistent pursuit of their potential
and they use the aggregation the
compounding and acceleration of building
an audience of people 10 of them that
love it automatically and then they
build and created and captured the 80
percent that they can love it and they
ignore the 10 to say this is the
stupidest thing ever I hate pimples
being popped sometimes more people that
hate you drive the people to love you to
engage with you more because they want
to protect and promote you because they
agree with you and they can't believe
you know I mean you know there's sites
out there that are just about hate yep I
like them I hope they post more about
Dave Meltzer because more people defend
me and feel better about me and engage
heavier into me what is your advice as a
top 100 business coach for Content
creators what's interesting about our
community and this is kind of my story
as well because a lot of us are
accidental entrepreneurs we didn't start
out to start a small business although
being a content creator and starting a
YouTube channel becomes a small business
or a big business or a big business or a
media company yeah and
um we didn't necessarily start out
thinking about how is this thing going
to scale or or we certainly are probably
lacking skills like leadership or team
building or so many different things
it's kind of the whole e-myth
um quandary where we just are creating
content and figuring out how to make a
little side income but it is just turned
into this whole Creator economy which is
insane how much money is in the system
and how much opportunity there is so as
a top 100 business go coach what is your
advice for those that are now trying to
learn business skills or advice that you
would recommend essentially startups
content creator startups that are
experiencing some success now and
money's coming in but now they're
overwhelmed with the growth or the
management or the business management
and they have a whole skill Gap because
their main thing was just creating
content and monetizing it yeah there's a
huge gap there and number one don't buy
into the bucket of top 100 anything or
top 10 anything I can buy those lists
and I was honored by Marshall Goldsmith
who said I'm a top 100 business coach
I'm a very good business coach but I
don't align with everyone in business
and not everybody can use me and I have
a waiting list for those that can and
those that can so make sure that you
trust everyone but vet the crap out of
them even if they have a top ten sure
moniker I just want to put that out
there as far as business skill look it's
the same thing you know I have so many
athletes celebrities entertainers that I
and military people that I transition
into business which is the same as a
content and greater and I always say Hey
you know you're the greatest football
player some of them live here that I
coach you're the greatest football
player that ever stepped on the field
and now you think they're going to do
business without coach but yet since you
were five and you were really good
naturally at football that since you
were five you you have had a coach now
you're going to get into business which
you may not be more naturally as
talented at and you don't need a coach
all of a sudden so I think the best
thing to do is get advisors and coaches
and the nice thing about YouTube not to
toot your horn too much is if you're
starting out and you can't afford a
coach like a professional football
player Entertainer for business you
can't afford a consultant or an advisor
YouTube's great yeah right find someone
who sits in this situation and that
advice is there and I think that's what
I try to provide with my content you do
the same this interview is doing the
same thing you know be humble say I
don't know what I don't know and go
ahead and find someone either on YouTube
or pay them depending on your timing and
risk tolerance and you will get there it
you know look it's still true you can
get the same education with a library
card I know people don't know what
libraries are but it's very true with a
library card you get the same education
as someone that goes to Harvard Business
School shopping bombs uh David what are
you working on what can people do to
follow you find you and what do you want
to promote to uh even add more value to
our community I really appreciate that
and to add value to the community what
I'd like to do is I'd like to send
anyone in your community my book for
free I'll pay for the book I'll pay for
shipping it's not one of those BS you
know get my book 10 bucks for shipping
meanwhile the books five bucks look I
have a best sellers I will pay for the
book and shipping and sign it if you
wanted to evaluate I'll sign it for you
too but I will offer your entire
community and so please you know go to
my YouTube David Meltzer or email me
directly David D Meltzer put in your
notes and so that's what I offer the
community I also do free Friday
trainings for over 23 years the replays
are on YouTube as well so but most
importantly just reach out and ask for
help I can either help you or I know
somebody that can help you David D
meltzer.com or David Meltzer on YouTube
in the other platform if you forget it
just remember my name Google me I am
blessed to be well known so David
Meltzer but my main mission is to
empower over a billion people to be
happy and you're not going to be able to
do something by yourself community means
opportunity the bigger your community
the bigger the opportunity so remember
my three favorite words ask for help
David I appreciate you so much thank you
for adding so much value to our
community today and there's so many
nuggets this will be an episode I think
people will return to and re-watch and
so we appreciate you and thanks for
being on the think media podcast anytime
I want to get you on my platforms as
well my TV shows and my podcasts uh I
know you have a lot you can offer my
community of middle-aged Mutant Turtles
thank you